26 billion dollars is a pretty big
ticket what did you think when you saw
the purchase price and the valuation
well I'm an active board member of
Microsoft and very enthused about the
stuff that company's doing I think it's
a great transaction LinkedIn brings a
lot you know I know Reid Hoffman Jeff
Weiner and the team there have built an
incredible audience and so combined with
what Microsoft does working with people
in productivity helping professionals
communicate until be a lot of synergies
there and so I was you know very
encouraging as that deal came together
and glad to see it that it really
happened so far investors haven't been
very supportive of the transaction
should they be well I the stock price is
going to jump up and down I'm no expert
on what the stock price should be day to
day I certainly think that the the value
of the two companies combined is greater
than the two by themselves but I love
the idea that the market wants us to
show that I mean the company is expert
in software and managing those audiences
and it's great that they now have an
opportunity to surprise the world and
say oh my god look
you know this feed this professional
feed and LinkedIn that is how I want to
learn about my career my company my
industry and I'm going back there if we
can make that as say valuable as the
Facebook feed is in the social world
that's huge value creation and that'll
happen over you know a period of years
you were CEO and chairman of the board
for a long time
you know well deal execution and
integration are always tricky especially
with the deal of this size what are the
keys to not screwing it up well I'm you
know they you've got great people
involved in this thing a lot of what
LinkedIn does will stay exactly the same
the idea of how you get the contact list
and the user profiles some of that
centered
is pretty easy without changing a lot of
the engineering so you know Microsoft
like most tech companies has had deals
that have gone better than others I
think we've got good preparation on this
one and the the nature of the synergies
is pretty clear